it's very helpful for people to hear
that they should make themselves
competent and dangerous and take their
proper place in the world competent and
dangerous
why dangerous because it's the
alternative to being weak
and weak is not good the people who
shoot up the high schools they're weak
they're weak how is it good to be
dangerous
because it makes you formidable
and life is a very difficult process and
it's not for
you're not prepared for it unless unless
you have the capacity for to be
dangerous
that doesn't mean that you should be
cruel it doesn't mean any of that
there's a statement in the new testament
the meek shall inherit the earth but the
meek isn't well translated it means
something more like
those who those who have swords and know
how to use them but keep them sheathed
will inherit the world
that's a way better way of thinking
about it you have to be powerful and
formidable and then peaceful in that
order right and that's not the same as
being naive and weak and harmless which
is what young men are being encouraged
to be it's like that's a very bad idea
it's a very bad idea because naive weak
and harmless means that you can't
withstand
the tragedies of life you can't bear any
responsibility you'll end up bitter and
when you get bitter then you get
dangerous but one thing i'm not getting
there's a big difference between letting
people do something for themself
and saying men should be dangerous
by dangerous that implies i should be
ready to threaten someone to hurt
somebody no you should be capable of it
but that doesn't mean you should use it
there's nothing to you otherwise like if
you're not a formidable force there's
not there's no morality in your
self-control
if you're incapable of violence not
being violent isn't a virtue people who
teach martial arts know this full well
right if you learn a martial art you
learn to be dangerous but simultaneously
you learn to control it both of those
come together and the combination of
that capacity for danger and the
capacity for control is what brings
about the virtue otherwise you confuse
weakness with with moral virtue i'm
harmless therefore i'm good it's like no
that isn't how it works that isn't how
it works at all if you're harmless
you're just weak and if you're weak
you're not going to be good you can't be
because it takes strength to be good
it's very difficult to be good
[Applause]
your critics your female critics say you
men are already stronger than we
you abuse us and you're encouraging that
oh well that's definitely not the case i
mean i've had tens of thousands of
people write me now and say that you
know they've taken my message to heart
they were nihilistic or addicted or
aimless or having trouble in their
relationships or not moving forward with
their partners their wives or
girlfriends and they've been trying to
develop a vision for their life and to
take responsibility and to quit
using deceit and they're better for it
and there's no downside to that for
anyone men and women alike and most of
the reason that men have been coming to
my lectures is i think part of that's
just an arbitrary baseline fluke almost
all the people who watch youtube are men
it's like 80 75 80 it's about the same
for me
so it might be that my message is
particularly attractive to young men or
it might just be that you know i was
particularly popular on youtube and
that's mostly a male domain yeah it's
popular with young men because you're
saying yeah go ahead abuse women i know
i've never said anything like that and i
think that that's that's
it's okay to hate trans people no it's
not okay particularly to hate anyone
maybe even your enemies
and my what i've talked about has
virtually nothing to do in any real
technical sense with trans people the
stance i took on blc16 was an
anti-compelled speech stance and i stand
by it
absolutely there's never been a piece of
legislation in the history of the
english common law that compelled
private speech not once
there has been legislation that
compelled commercial speech so for
example if you sell tobacco you have to
put a warning on the product
but that's commercial speech it's very
very limited and even that's been
extraordinarily limited the supreme
court in the us in the 1940s came out
and stated forthrightly that there was
to be no compelled speech uh generated
by the legis the
and the executive branches that that was
unconstitutional and it violates english
common law tradition and the fact that
it has to do with transgender people is
virtually irrelevant the issue is
compelled speech and if it wasn't the
issue this would have died away all the
scandals surrounding this would have
died away 18 months ago it's not what
it's about it's about the government and
the ideologues that are pushing this
sort of legislation attempting to
exercise
tyrannical control over voluntary speech
and that's a no-go zone as far as i'm
concerned so somebody wants to be called
zee or zur
why not i don't care what people want to
be called that's fine but that doesn't
mean i should be compelled by law to
call them that the government has
absolutely no business whatsoever ever
governing the content of your voluntary
speech like i don't even like hate
speech laws i think they're a big
mistake and that says what you can't say
right this is what you have to say
that's a whole different that's a whole
difference so you were personally
willing to accommodate people if they
want to be called something odd we could
have a conversation about that and if i
was convinced that you knew why you were
asking that was actually in your best
interest
that and you weren't just attempting to
exercise ideological control over me for
reasons that had absolutely nothing to
do with you personally then i might
consider it in my private conversation
just like i would if you asked me to use
a nickname for example
so but there's a big difference between
privately negotiated modes of address
and
legislatively demanded compelled speech
it really has nothing to do with
transgender people or except
peripherally the transgender issue
[Music]
you